- He's an aerospace engineer,
noted for designing light,
strong, unusual looking,
energy efficient aircrafts.
He designed the record breaking Voyager,
which was the first plane
to fly around the world
without stopping or refueling.
He designed the first
privately funded space craft
to enter space twice
within a two week period.
He's Burt Rutan and here are
his top ten rules for success.
- [Burt] Someone ask him
what's the most difficult thing
about going to the moon.
- [Man] Copy.
- And then he says the will to do it.
The engineering is just calculations
but the decision and
the will and the courage
to try to do it, is the
most difficult hurdle.
- [Man] (mumbles) 105
- We are known for trying new things,
even though we have a tough schedule.
We did an airplane that the
customer wanted it flying within
I think it was eight and a half months
and we elected on our own
to try a totally new manufacturing method
for the wings and tail
services and control services.
Something that hadn't been done before.
Something that may not work.
Something that was really
exciting and interesting
and if it did work,
it's breakthrough stuff.
Our first astronaut, Alan Shepard,
who flew a sub-orbinal flight
followed Gagarin by only three weeks.
After Shepard's flight, it took
only seven and a half years
for us to launch Apollo 8 to
go out and orbit the moon.
They went to the moon on
the very first man flight
of the big Saturn 5.
Now can you imagine today,
NASA developing a brand new,
huge, big advanced rocket
and the first time people fly on it,
they go to the moon
or they go somewhere
we've never been before.
That puts in perspective
the kind of risks that we,
that we were taking
and those who put themselves in a position
to take enormous risks are
those that have breakthroughs
and those that have research results.
I believe that confidence in
nonsense is a major factor
and the reason is, think of
the most important breakthrough
that you can think of.
Go back before it was
recognized as a breakthrough
and the populous normally would consider,
well that's nonsense.
That's nonsensical.
Now all of a sudden when it really is
recognized as a true
breakthrough then of course,
oh yeah, that's really cool.
But what people forget
is it's nonsense before.
And what that means,
that's why the weird folk
have the breakthroughs
because they have confidence in nonsense.
If it's nonsensical and you say,
well I'm not going to try to do that,
it doesn't make sense,
you're not going to have a breakthrough.
The guy who is silly enough to think that
Hey I'll try that even
though it's nonsense,
he's the guy that's going
to have the breakthrough.
So, try things that you
don't think will work.
If you think they'll work,
you're not doing research anyway.
You're going to have failures
if you try hard stuff.
If you go out and try to
build a, a better seaplane
and your goal is to go 12 knots faster,
you're probably not going to fail.
You may fail because it
only goes four knots faster
but it's not going to
be a disaster failure.
But if you go out and try something
that is, Holy crap,
can you really do that?
And it fails, it is a failure.
And I feel very strongly
that it's not good enough
for us to have generations of kids
that think that it's okay to look forward
to a better version of a
cellphone with a video in it.
They need to look forward to exploration.
They need to look forward to colonization.
They need to look
forward to breakthroughs.
They need to.
We need to inspire them
because they need to lead us
and help us survive in the future.
What I try to encourage people to do
is to have a breakthrough by finding a way
to do it more simply.
And even if the real simple
one has a chance of not working
because it's too simple,
well try it anyway.
Because in trying it,
sometimes you'll stumble unto a solution
on why it wouldn't work
and now you've really had a big gain.
Now you have a simple thing that does work
and that's the real challenge now.
You can always make something
work by adding complexity
but you can never make
something affordable
by adding complexity.
I think breakthroughs occur
not when everybody's doing fine
and when your priority is to
make everyone equally happy,
you don't have breakthroughs then.
That's monotony and that
can lead to monotony
and it can lead, even to
your ability to survive.
But you have breakthroughs
either during or after crises,
when you have really bad times.
We're creative when we're threatened.
I think the world of aviation
will gain from me mostly inspiration.
The fact that a few people
literally in a garage or a
small shop built an airplane
that doubled and absolute distance record,
flew all the way around the world,
flew through all this weather
and came back home safely,
the fact that that was done all composite
without mixing metals
without solving all these stupid problems
that the engineers make for themselves,
that will provide the inspiration,
that my God, it can be done.
We're going to do it.
We'll stick our necks out.
I knew how the Wright brothers felt
when they came upon these things
and had success.
We decided, this is the
best way to pun this.
What's one thing
and that was the passion
that I saw in your eyes
for the outcome.
And I knew that you would stick with it
because I knew that passion was genuine.
When you go out and
look to venture capital
or look to whatever,
you're looking for people
who have a passion for money.
But you have a passion for stage flight
and I think that's the difference between
- Excuse me.
(audience laughs)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jeremiah Omara asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Burt Rutan's
top ten rules for success
you love the most.
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.